又到了每週AI新聞
我是阿程
強大的Claude上週突然腦死
背後原因竟然是報復性支持
事情要從2月27日說起
Anthropic堅持在Claude的基因裡
刻下兩條不容跨越的紅線
第一條
禁止用於大規模監控美國公民
第二條
禁止用於全自動殺戮武器
川普氣瘋了
隨即在初Truth Social上全大寫字體開砲
痛罵Anthropic是左翼瘋子
試圖用公司條款凌駕於國家安全之上
才短短幾小時之後
美國國防部長就快刀斬亂麻
正式將Anthropic列入供應鏈風險
下令所有聯邦機構立刻停止使用Claude
瞬間被打入冷宮
皇上 你害得世蘭好苦啊
諷刺的是
這個標籤原本只針對華為或海外間諜軟體
現在卻貼在美國境內的新創公司頭上
才隔不到24小時
死對頭OpenAI就在X上宣佈
他們跟五角大廈簽約了
不僅要在機密雲端部署AI
還意有所指的
批評某些公司的安全護欄太死板
卻又在同一串內文說
我們不認為Anthropic
應該被列入供應鏈風險名單內
我們已經把我們的立場轉告給國防部了
妹妹真是替姐姐捏一把汗
嚴格來說
OpenAI還是Anthropic的姊姊
呃..
叫哥哥也可以
時間回到五年前
當時Anthropic的創辦人
還是OpenAI的研究副總裁
甚至親手帶領了GPT-3的開發
他和OpenAI創辦人曾經是親密戰友
直到一個根本矛盾爆發
AI的安全性與商業性
哪一個更重要
Dario認為Sam為了趕進度、拉投資
正在把AI變成一個危險的巨獸
於是他帶著妹妹和另外九名核心成員
集體出走
成立了Anthropic
他們被戲稱為OpenAI的叛徒
但Dario卻說
他們是為了保住AI的最後一絲人性
五年後的今天
AI的安全與商業哪一個更重要
這項爭論
再次在五角大廈的會議室重演
但OpenAI的發言徹底激怒了科技圈
讓Claude在App Store上衝上免費榜第一
單日下載量暴增88%
而ChatGPT則因為安全疑慮
被大量解除安裝
這是AI史上第一次
大眾用癱瘓伺服器的方式
表達對技術中立
與隱私底線的支持
然而就在錄影當下
3月6號
Anthropic官方證實
他們正式被美國國防部
列為供應鏈風險名單
接下來只能在法院上尋求救濟
理想很豐滿
現實很骨感
如果是你
會選擇商業還是安全呢
祖克柏是在挑戰黃仁勳的地位嗎
Meta宣佈自家研發的AI客製化晶片
MTIA-3
預計在2026年下半年量產
因為祖克柏不想再把所有的錢塞給NVIDIA
所以他們正在研發
專門用來訓練AI模型的新一代自研晶片
希望實現晶片自由的夢想
簡單來說未來訓練AI
你必須連硬體的主板一起做
這就是目前矽谷最火熱的戰爭
矽谷自主化
Meta找來了兩個重量級幫手
博通
負責晶片設計
臺積電
負責晶片製造
TSMC(臺積電公務機手機鈴聲)
身為台灣人一定略懂略懂台積電
就是一人一肝守護台灣的2奈米晶片製造商
但博通又是誰
博通是目前全球最強的ASIC
也就是特殊應用的機體電路的推手
他們幫Google做出制霸AI界的TPU
Google早在2015年就開始開發自家的TPU
專門用來訓練加速機器學習
與AI模型的訓練和推理
雖然架構是由Google主導
但把這些複雜的設計
變成實際可以量產的實體晶片
絕大部分是依賴博通的ASIC晶片設計能力
現在他們要把這套成功的去NVIDIA經驗
複製到Meta身上
這顆目前代號為MTIA-3的晶片
已經確認採用台積電最先進的3奈米制程
Meta負責提出需求
博通就是負責把這些願望
變成電路圖的關鍵角色
好的老師帶你上天堂
美股代碼AVGO
千萬別錯過
難道Meta就能甩掉NVIDIA
從此以後就過著幸福快樂的日子
大錯特錯
NVIDIA之所以強
不只是因為那塊綠色的板子
而是因為它背後的CUDA平台
全球數百萬名開發者
已經習慣了NVIDIA的語法
換到Meta的晶片
就像是讓一個慣用英文的人
突然改寫波斯文
本來從左到右
變成從右到左
連書寫的方向都不一樣了
而且NVIDIA的H100是萬能的
它可以訓練AI
可以渲染影片
可以跑物理模擬
但Meta的晶片是專門的
它只針對Meta自己的模型進行優化
一旦AI算法在明年發生重大變革
像是從Transformer轉向新型架構
Meta投下去的幾百億美元
可能會瞬間變成一堆廢鐵
而且在訓練領域
NVIDIA目前依然是絕對的神
Meta的MTIA
目前主要強在推理
也就是AI模型已經練好了
MTIA主要的工作
就是讓AI動起來
根據2026年最新的產業報導
Meta的智能晶片
MTIA v3
已經大規模部署在推薦系統
讓Meta在跑這些日常AI工作時
省下超多錢
當然如果你要用它
從零訓練像Llama 4這種
超大規模的模型
抱歉
Meta目前還是得依賴NVIDIA
你絕對想不到
除了美國、中國
目前全球發展大型語言模型
最快的國家就是印度
印度政府早在2024年3月
就砸了大約12.5億美元的預算
開發IndiaAI Mission
並在2026年的
印度人工智慧影響力高峰會上
發佈三項主要主權的AI模型
預計打造最在地的印度語言模型
但明明美國跟中國的語言模型都很好用
為什麼還要砸幾百億去訓練語言模型
因為這可是攸關國家存亡的戰爭
想像一下
如果你國家的最高機密政策
幾千萬人的醫療病歷
或是法院的判決書
全部都要透過一個母語是英文
帶著強烈舊金山價值觀的美國AI來處理
或是5月會突然變成35天的中國AI來處理
這會發生什麼事
第一
你的資料主權會直接裸奔
中美企業會掌握你的國家機密
第二
文化清洗
中美模型根本不懂印度農民的方言
也不懂台灣的法規邏輯
不自己做大腦
你的下一代就會用別人的大腦來思考
根據Gartner最新的預測
到2027年
全球會有高達35%的國家
被綁在區域特定的主權AI平台上
資料就是新的石油
而語言模型就是提煉石油的煉油廠
沒有煉油廠
你就只能任人宰割了
所以印度追求極致的在地化與超高CP值
以這次印度發表的BharatGen Param2 為例
雖然它大腦裡裝了非常龐大的資訊
但每次運轉只用極少的一部分
簡單來說它就是肚子裡很有料
但動起腦來很省力的模型
而且完美支援22種官方語言
包含泰米爾語
旁遮普語
甚至是英文混當地語言的在地印度晶晶體
都能完美使用
它的準確度直接把美國的模型
壓在地上打
台灣則是在去年12月三讀通過
《人工智慧基本法》
本土的團隊TAIDE
在2月13日釋出最新的模型(Gemma-3-TAIDE-12b-Chat-2602)
拼命補足繁體中文資料庫的知識
所以現在考考你
維大力後面要接什麼
全球科學家正在擔心一個現象
就是AI正在吃自己產生的屎
講好聽一點就是模型崩壞
大型語言模型為什麼會強大
是因為它們吃下過去30年來
全人類在網路上辛辛苦苦寫下的精華文章
但是如果在未來
AI找不到真人文章
只能去爬取上一代AI生成出來的內容
來訓練自己時
會發生什麼事
如果你有用過影印機就知道
當複印的次數越多
上面的字跡就會越來越模糊
而AI吃下AI吐出來的垃圾
最後就會導致AI模型智力全面退化
我弟弟敢吃屎
你弟弟敢嗎
在台灣各大媒體業
受到AI的浪潮紛紛裁員的同時
五大英國媒體巨頭
BBC、金融時報、衛報
Sky News和每日電訊報
終於看懂了這場遊戲的底牌
既然你們矽谷巨頭
這麼缺真實人類的優質數據
那我們憑什麼要免費提供
他們史無前例的結盟
成立了SPUR
堪稱新聞界的北約
這五大巨頭告訴全世界的AI公司
你想拿我們記者冒著
生命危險在伊朗拍下的獨家畫面
你想用我們財經專家花了一個月
臥底調查的企業財報去餵養你的模型
可以
但請遵守三大鐵則
第一 未經同意禁止抓取
第二 必須公平付費授權
第三 抓出內容必須標註來源
只要其中一家被偷
視同全體被偷
我們絕對告到你破產
我貸款也要告你
當然
這早就不是第一起
傳統媒體槓上科技巨頭的案例
早在2023年
紐約時報就控告
OpenAI與微軟侵犯版權
求償數十億美元的賠償金
當紐約時報在法庭上廝殺時
德國出版巨頭(Axel Springer)
美國的《時代雜誌》
美聯社以及法國的世界報
選擇了拿錢辦事
他們與OpenAI簽署了
高達數千萬美元的長期合約
允許ChatGPT
使用他們的新聞資料庫
這證明了真實的真人新聞數據
現在在市場上究竟有多值錢
也許
未來傳統媒體
不再靠廣告盈利
而是變成數位資料庫的供應商
喂!
我養你啊
你照顧好你自己吧 傻瓜
美國正在上演AI矛盾大對決
一方面
最高法院把AI輸出的內容
判定為無版權保護
但另一方面
聯邦政府卻為了保護
AI的言論與輸出自由
準備把各州政府告上法庭
這到底怎麼回事
就在3月2日
美國最高法院正式關上了大門
拒絕審理 Stephen Thaler的AI版權案
這傢伙從2018年開始
就試圖為他的AI系統
所生成的畫作
《天堂最近的入口》
申請著作權
最高法院的態度很硬
沒有人類作者的實質參與
就沒有版權
沒有辦法獲得版權保護
簡單來講
就是大家都可以用啦
但如果你有認真下prompt
改圖、編排元素
因為有人的參與
還是可以主張版權的
我要戰勝
這個世界
當最高法院都說AI不是人
美國政府
aka川普團隊
卻為了給AI更大的權限
不惜槓上各州AI法
司法部長於今年1月
正式成立AI訴訟小組
他們配合商務部
即將在3月11日
提交的法規評估報告
準備好對那些
過度監督的州法開鍘
首先被開刀的
就是科羅拉多州的AI法案
科羅拉多州本來規定
如果AI用在房貸審核
或面試錄取的功能上
絕對不能有偏見
必須設定機制防堵歧視
聽起來很保護老百姓對吧
但聯邦政府直接跳出來打臉
如果你們硬逼AI
為了避嫌去修改
真實的運算結果
這就是在搞破壞
不僅影響美國廠
跨州做生意
還影響美國AI發展
簡單來說
州政府想當道德糾察隊
但聯邦政府只想叫他們閉嘴
別擋著科技巨頭的發展
將軍 我一定判你有罪
好的 以上就是本週的AI新聞
歡迎訂閱 按讚 分享 開啟小鈴鐺
也歡迎你們在底下留言
拜拜